Ukraine's new foreign minister pavlo
klimkin arrived in Luxembourg with high
expectations the support of the
presidential peace plan the precondition
which are critical for the realization
of the peace plan wishes effective
control of the border and the
implementation of the display and as a
fall but those gathering here now
implementing Ukraine's 15-point peace
plan will be difficult their message
Russia needs to stop helping the
separatists and support Kiev's
initiatives defense plant on President
poroshenko onto the younger president
poroshenko's peace plan and the
ceasefire is not only a brave step but
also a decisive step via often gets
we're hoping now and expecting that
Russia will be open for cooperation
Britain threatened further sanctions of
that cooperation doesn't come but Russia
should be in no doubt President Putin
should be in no doubt now that in the
European Union we are ready to take
those measures a lot of work has gone on
on preparing wider sanctions it's a view
that's several other foreign ministers
back and a decision could be taken
swiftly EU leaders are due to meet in
brussels on friday if they are not
satisfied they could impose further
economic penalties on russia